we're told to factor r squared plus 4r
minus 45. and there are simpler ways to
factor this because this has one as a
leading coefficient on the r squared
right here what we're going to do is
we're going to factor this by grouping
when you factor it by grouping what you
want to do is find two numbers whose
products so the two numbers are a and b
whose product is equal to the
coefficient on r squared 1 times
negative 45 which is just negative 45
and whose sum is equal to the
coefficient on the first degree term is
equal to 4.
a plus b
is equal to 4. so let's look at all of
the different combinations that gets to
negative 45 and see if when you add them
you ever get to 4.
so let's take the combinations
let's take
let's look at the different a's and b's
and let's see what happens when you sum
them
so i could try 1 and negative 45 but if
you take their sum that's not going to
get you anywhere close to 4 even if you
swap them negative one and positive
forty-five let's see if you do
three and fifteen those are way more
three and negative fifteen or negative
three and fifteen those are way more
than four apart we have to find numbers
that are closer together so let's see
three four five and nine that looks
interesting five and nine are four apart
and we we if we go with five
and negative nine
if we go with five and negative nine
what's their sum their sum is negative
4. what happens if we go with negative 5
and positive 9.
well then their sum is 4. so negative 5
and positive 9 works so we want to do
here now that we found the numbers whose
product is equal to the 1 times negative
45 and whose sum is equal to 4. let's
break this 4r up into a sum of
negative 5
negative let me break it up this way
into
9r
minus 5r i broke that 4r into that using
our two numbers and then i could put the
r squared out front r squared and then
we have a minus 45 and now we're ready
to group this and then factor by
grouping so let's look at this first
group right here
they both have the common factor of r so
let's factor out an r this is equal to r
times r squared divided by r is r 9r
divided by r is 9.
so that's that first group
and the second group right here
has a common factor
of negative 5. so let's factor it out
negative minus 5
minus 5 negative 5r divided by negative
5 is just an r negative 45 divided by
negative 5 is a 9.
and then we have an r plus 9 in both
terms
r times r plus 9 negative 5 times r plus
9. so we can factor that out so you
factor an r plus 9 out
r plus 9 and you're left with you're
left with r times r plus 9 divided by r
plus 9 is just going to be an r
and then negative five times r plus nine
divided by r plus nine is negative five
and we're done